meanwhile an unprecedented move in Italy
as the corona virus continues to spread
the Prime Minister has put a total
lockdown for all 60 million people until
next month
Italy has the biggest cluster of cases
outside of China with at least 463
deaths and more than 7,300 infected
patients at this time amy kellogg is
live in florence this morning hey Amy hi
Sandra well there have been rolling and
regional restrictions over the past few
weeks here as as you're well aware but
the Prime Minister really took Italians
by surprise as they were tucking into
their dinners last night by saying I
have a new decree for the whole nation
and that can be summarized as I will
stay at home now it is not clear how
stringent these new rules will be how
they will be enforced but a document a
sort of permission slip that needs to be
filled out by every person who chooses
to move around has been published it has
to go to the interior ministry and be
approved
now it's jut not just movement anymore
into and out of northern Italy that is
being restricted again theoretically now
the entire country of Italy is under
lockdown notice that a few there will no
longer be a red zone there will no
longer be a zone one or a zone 2 on our
peninsula there will be Italy that is a
protected zone people obviously became
very panicked last night after hearing
about this about having enough
provisions there are lines outside
supermarkets where they're letting
people in in small numbers and really
enforcing that 3 foot distance rule the
situation outside prisons meanwhile
remains tense with police weary of
further disturbances after riots broke
out in two dozen prisons after
restrictions on gatherings and
visitations there were announced for
prisons and that remains calm this
morning however very tense now again
Sandra it is not clear exactly how this
is going to work out I snuck out to get
a few provisions this morning and there
are a lot of sort of holes and
inconsistencies and how it's all working
but basically the idea is that in order
to
limit the spread of cases hear what the
government is trying its best to do is
limit contact between people so nobody
is kind of expanding their circle either
inadvertently or on purpose in Florence
for us this morning Amy thank you